[Music]
last week police
in washington state made an arrest in
the 30-year-old killing of a canadian
couple
she had been sexually assaulted and shot
in the back of the head
he had been beaten and strangled
there was plenty of dna evidence but
nobody really
to point a finger off
[Music]
for 31 years there was basically no
resolution but then the power of using
genetics and genealogy was able to
get the name of a suspect within a day
because of the sort of analysis we can
now do
you can discover things about the
relatives of people who have
uploaded their genetic information to
the internet and i think that's
what's both the power of this method and
also the thing that raises a lot of
these
disquieting questions about privacy and
consent
that we're going through right now we're
evolving how dna shows who you're
connected to
[Music]
genetics is this thing that we think of
as cutting edge science you know it's
happening in some of the most
advanced labs in the world and genealogy
is something that you know maybe
makes you think of your grandparents you
know looking up records maybe going to
churches
and looking at gravestones to kind of
try and trace your family tree back
so genetic genealogy is what happens
when you combine
those two sciences a family tree
represents so much more than history
so in the mid 2000s
this new industry started to grow
based on the rise of an of a consumer
dna testing
uh industry um and that was something
that came out of the sequencing of a
human genome
basically companies trying to figure out
how to make this a consumer product
i decided to have my dna tested through
ancestry dna the big surprise was
we're not german at all
family tree dna was the first company on
the scene
they were really targeting hardcore
genealogists and then you have companies
that are more targeted
at a broader commercial audience start
coming into the scene
now jed match really was an important
breakthrough
in genetic genealogy because what it did
was it created an
open source site where if you had done
ancestry's
dna tests you could also compare your
results to
people who had done other tna tests but
you know my dna
isn't just my dna it's my cousin's dna
it's my mom's dna
and so when i make a decision to share
my dna
i'm also making a decision to share
their dna
so uh at this point
at least 30 million people have have
taken these consumer dna
tests some large portion of those people
have also
uploaded the results to these public
databases
that are searchable by anyone who's
curious
30 million might not seem like a big
number to you
of course you know there's billions of
people in the world
but the reason that number is
significant is that
you don't necessarily have to have
shared your genetic information
in order for your information to be
exposed so
there was one study that found that
just two percent of people in the world
would need to share their genetic
information for us to potentially be
able
to identify everybody
i'm joined right now with genetic
genealog genealogist that's a mouthful
right there cece moore
hi how are you it's great to meet you
i'm happy to be here so
cece moore is probably one of the most
interesting people that i have
ever interviewed she started off her
career as a model
actress at one point she
made a living playing barbie and at one
point
she decided that she wanted to
make a family tree as a gift for her
niece
who was getting married this sort of
became
this pretty all-consuming uh pastime for
her
and she didn't have you know formal
scientific training it's just that she
was doing a lot of this and through sort
of
trial and error she realized the way
that you could merge
these traditional genealogical methods
with the genetic information and also um
social media she came up with this idea
of triangulating
your relatives to discover the hidden
identity of someone
and then she became the genetic
genealogist on this tv show called
finding your roots so take a look at
this family tree
this is christian kumal and teresa
stockhausen we traced another of their
descendants
and found one of their great-grandsons
who was willing to test for us
so as cece moore is helping all these
adoptees find their birth parents
people begin asking the question of what
else
can we use this technique for and
there's one
really obvious answer to what else you
can use that for
and that is figuring out who committed a
crime
june 18th 1976 marked the first
known rape by the east area rapist
the golden state killer was this serial
murderer rapist who terrorized
california in the 70s
there was plenty of dna evidence but
nobody really
to point a finger off so it became a
cold case and then
uh in the spring of 2018
there was this announcement of the
solving of this
uh decades-old case that had used these
methods
to basically identify the suspect
cece moore sees this as a green light
she gets in contact with this company
called parabon which can take really
degraded dna samples and extract
information out of them and make the
same sort of genetic
profile the same kind of file that you
would get from a 23andme or an ancestry
she had already been in contact with a
few
police departments and detectives across
the country
including detectives in snohomish county
washington where there had been a
very brutal murder
[Music]
21 year old jay cook and 18 year old
tanya van kylenburg
were murdered while visiting seattle
from victoria british columbia
there were a few clues there was this
blue blanket that the
one of the bodies had been wrapped in
and there was dna
in 1987 happens to be the very dawn
of the dna analysis era in law
enforcement
but there are really severe limitations
to that it's really more of a
confirmation tool
than like a true detective tool and even
as these databases grew
there weren't any matches this should
tell us which ones we can be more
confident
about cece gets to work doing her part
which is trying to figure out how
what kinds of records and stuff you can
use to build out this family tree
not every crime scene dna sample will
have a relative that has uploaded their
genetic information
so you kind of have to win the lottery
and cece
won big she didn't just get one match
she got two so basically whoever
gave that sample the suspect has
two relatives in the ged match database
and they're pretty good
matches in the context of genetic
genealogy they're they're second cousins
and when she built out the family trees
there was only
one male that was the right amount of
relatedness
to the genetic hits and dead match and
they knew from other evidence that they
were looking for a mail so it was
very strong indication very quickly of
who their suspect might be
the suspect happened to be a truck
driver so they followed
him around in his truck for a few days
and that at one point
a coffee cup falls out of the truck when
he's pulling away from a traffic light
and they are able to test the saliva on
the lip
of the coffee cup and it matches
yesterday we took into custody a
55-year-old seatac man
who is suspected of the 1987 murders of
jay cooke
and tanya van kylenburg we the jury find
the defendant william earl talbott ii
guilty of defense
it's an incredible testament to the
power
of these tools given the right kind of
data someone
with cc's abilities is able to sift
through an enormously large data set
and come back with a single name
so to go from entertainment and then
end up in a science career in my 40s is
definitely not something i would have
ever imagined without genetic genealogy
this case never would have been solved
cc moore did in two hours
what 20 or 30 cops couldn't do in 30
years
i think most people don't realize the
power
of these types of tests when this
happened
there was sort of this agreement okay we
can use this very
powerful technology to solve cold cases
but very quickly people started to use
the technology
for other things for uh murders that
were not long unsolved and i think when
that happened
that started to raise the level of
discomfort people had
the particularly sticky thing here is
that you're not just sharing your
information you're sharing your family's
information
and that's a tough thing especially when
we know things like
the criminal justice system
disproportionately
targets minorities right or when we know
that sometimes dna
evidence is wrong
and i think another part of the
cautionary aspect of this is that this
is a
this is an application of genetic
analysis that nobody dreamed of
when we set out to
sequence the human genome and it's only
through this combination of these
obsessive people with their weird
interests discovering this tool
that we have ended up here and so i
think
there's bound to be other totally
unforeseen uses for this
that we can't even imagine right now
somebody
might find out you know about your
family
health history for example a life
insurer if they knew that you were prone
to heart attacks
they would be able to use that
information to deny you a policy
so it's not just you know crime suspects
that face exposure with this information
all of us could be exposed in one way or
another once this information is out
there
it's an enormously rich data trove that
a lot of people have decided to make
public
and perhaps the people who've uploaded
it haven't fully thought through
the implications
you